Looking at the VDR genes of my genetics report, I will a little bit confused.
There are 11 primary genes listed.
The blue red arrows and metrics are confusing me.
So the blue and red arrows that are up and down arrows are suggested that the data suggests defects either up-regulate that gene
or down-regulate that gene.
So that's what that means.
Now, if it doesn't have an arrow at all, it's typically thought that that gene is down-regulated.
However, if it's got a down arrow, then there's a ton of data that says it definitely down-regulates that gene.
If I have a VDR gene, the VDR gene or the vitamin D receptor gene, so this person's talking about vitamin D absorption.
So, if the arrow is down, that means if I have a defector that gene, it's going to be strongly down-regulated.
If it's up, then it doesn't mean strongly, it just means the research is opposite of what is typically normally thought.
Now, I'll finish this question.
For example, the first gene that F-O-K-L-G, the VDR, F-O-K-L-G, has a blue upward arrow next to it,
a one-variant and a metric of GA 46.8.
That means you have a single allele defect of the VDR, F-O-K-L gene,
and it is a gene that typically up-regulates absorption,
and that percentage 46.8 is at 46.8% of the people also have that identical variant, meaning they have a one-variant.
So, that really means nothing, okay?
So, it means that that's really a mute point.
So, I wouldn't say there's anything wrong with your VDR genes based upon that.
The next eight all have downward pointed arrows, man, right?
It only means it's bad if you have defects.
So, it means that it's down, the defects of those genes strongly down-regulate that the vitamin D receptor.
So, if the person has ones or two's out there or a lot of ones or several two's on some of those eight genes,
then they're going to have a more difficult time getting their vitamin D levels up.
But, you said you have no variants and all metrics are 90% or higher.
So, those are not common genes to have defects on, because 99% of the people have no defects on those genes.
The last two, one of which is the Taki gene, the TAQI gene,
but one that you mentioned specifically a couple weeks ago have no arrows.
One variant and the metrics are close to 47%.
So, if you only have a single little defect, half the people in the country have that same defect,
then that means that that's not a major issue.
Now, the Taki gene doesn't have an arrow because there's a whole data set about the Taki gene that that is a big player in vitamin D receptor issues.
So, does that mean that you're going to have major issues with vitamin D? No, it doesn't.
Again, when you look at your genes, you have a blank, which means you don't have any defect on the gene.
You have a one, maybe you have a single little defect on the gene, or you have a two, you have a double little defect on the gene.
Really, what you're really looking for are the two's.
Most your genes, because most your genes, when you have a defect, it's going to down-regulate that gene pathway.
So, when you're really looking at the two's, or let's say out of these 11 genes in the BDR genes, if you had ones and two's on all of them,
and they were very uncommon gene.
So, it's for person to have defect.
So, instead of it say 46%, it was only 6%.
At least 6% of the population have that same defect you do.
And you have other gene defects in that same family of genes, then you're probably going to have more of a problem with that gene.
So, that's how I assess your genes, you know, that what's the greater chance you have in a problem.
And remember, when you're looking at genetics, just because you have all two's, it doesn't mean it's not going to work.
It just means you have a chance of it not working, you know, greater chance of it not working than somebody who doesn't have those defects.
So, you recommended taking smaller doses more frequently, and my functional doctor wants me to switch to liposomal D.
And above that, the sentence was, so my genetics, are my genetics a problem with absorbing D. Do you think I'd have had higher labyrinths in the last few doses?
So, I don't think your genetics are really an issue with you absorbing D.
So, remember, like absorbing the nutrient, when we have the vitamin D receptor genes to look at what's vitamin D, there's other factors too.
How damaged is my epithelial wall? You know, do I have leaky gut issues? Do I have other issues?
You know, if I have a concurrent with vitamin D, if I have a concurrent autoimmune issue, that's going to be gobbled up by vitamin D giving me low vitamin D levels.
So, if I have issues with fat absorbed in general, because I had my gallbladder removed, or I have a very slungish gallbladder, so I'm going to have it more difficult time absorbing fat-soluble nutrition.
So, there's other factors, not just genetics, so you want to look at other factors. Will taking liposomal vitamin D be better? Maybe.
So, only one way to find out is to try it and see if that raises your levels. Typically, taking liposomal vitamins is better.
The only thing that I would say about vitamin D is that vitamin D is already a fat-soluble vitamin. I don't know that rapid in a fat. That's what liposomal nutrition is.
It's a nutrient that's basically wrapped in a fat so that you have a better chance of absorbing it.
I don't know how the better... I haven't seen the studies that better absorbed with liposomal D or not.
You know, doing liposomal glutathione or the liposomal C or the other liposomals on nutrients that are tend to be more difficult to absorb makes more sense.
But we just don't know. It's just something you certainly can try and then look at your levels and see if it makes a difference.